caroline je sais que vous vouliez parler
de youppi et de son quarantième
anniversaire est pas comme ça parce
qu'il n'a aucun cheveu gris mais youpi
c'est vraiment une institution à
montréal d'abord ça fait 40 ans qu'il
est en fonctions d'abord vous rappeler
il était la mascotte des expos de 1979 à
2004 il y en fait inusité des choses
qu'on oublie parfois sur youpi ça a été
la première mascotte a été expulsé d'un
match officiel du baseball majeur et
c'est grâce à tommy lasorda qui n'était
pas très heureux que youppi saute sur
l'abri des joueurs
en 2005 il le réussit deux records à la
fois il est devenu la première mascotte
est la mascotte du canadien de montréal
alors qu'on voit les images lorsqu'il a
perdu son pari avec jimmy fallon en 2014
angels ont éliminé le canadien il dû
porter le chandail des reds partout en
ville mais ce que je faisais donc c'est
qu'en 2005 il est devenu la première
mascotte du canadien est également la
première mascotte officie dans deux
ligues sportives la ligue de baseball
majeur bien sûr et la ligue nationale de
hockey
et saviez-vous que youppi est également
l'oeuvre de la même artiste qui a crié
les mots pète entre autres miss piggy et
oui tout à fait c'est une certaine boni
ericsson qui a conçu le costume de
youppi donc quelques faits a noté qui
vous serviront sûrement dans quelques
jeux de société quelconque à noël l'an
prochain